يحب الجميع أن يسمعوا أن الشوكولاتة
يمكن أن تكون مفيدة لهم والحقيقة هي
أنه يمكن أن تكون كذلك ولكن هناك بعض
المحاذير الأولى للشوكولاتة فقط لأن
بعض المكونات الموجودة فيها تميل إلى
زيادة معدل الأيض الخاص بك.
أنت
تحترق بمجرد الجلوس هناك ، فهذا
يمنحك أيضًا بعض السعرات الحرارية بشكل واضح ولكن
عندما تأخذ كلا هذين الأمرين
بالمقارنة ، فإنك تحرق قليلاً
أكثر مما تتناوله طالما
أنك لا تفرط في ذلك.  شوكولاتة جيدة
ولا توجد شوكولاتة جيدة جدًا ،
ربما سمعت أن الشوكولاتة
الداكنة التي من المحتمل أن
تكون أفضل رهان لك بالإضافة إلى هذا
التأثير الأيضي ، فهي غنية أيضًا
بمضادات الأكسدة التي
ستساعد في تنظيف بعض  الخلايا القذرة في
شوكولاتة الكاكاو في جسمك ليست
شائعة تمامًا ولكن يمكن أن يكون لها بعض
الفوائد الصحية بالإضافة إلى أنها يمكن أن تخفض
المستويات السيئة من الكوليسترول المعروف باسم
LDL ويمكن أن تساعد في رفع مستويات HDL الجيدة
قليلاً.  بت تريد منا أن نجد
حوالي ستين أو سبعين بالمائة من الكاكاو
في الشوكولاتة التي قد تشتريها ، لذا إذا
كنت تريد أن تعيش حتى المائة ، يمكنك
تناول الشوكولاتة ولكن قليلاً فقط